okay hello everyone
welcome to another
design review language completeness and
consistency
discussion for
post version 13 wolfram language
all right we have a
variety of miscellaneous topics here so
let's start off with lock return
returning dollar timed out
oh i was needed uh so
yes when we last discussed dollar timed
out we decided that
it should be reserved for users and that
generally
system functions should return failure
objects and you know that was a
discussion i think about 18 months ago
but then in the spring we introduced
with lock which returns dollar timed out
and so
i am pointing out this contradiction and
[Music]
i think it was a mistake that woodlock
returns timed out does anybody disagree
that that was a mistake
well
two things one is dollar time doubt was
at that time documented so i felt free
to
to use it and second it's not really an
error i mean a failure object it's a
signals
that
the time constraint that you set
was was reached i mean the default time
constraint is infinity so you never see
it unless you are actually uh prepared
to to deal with it so we need an easy
way to discover that value and we're not
sure failure object is okay so the way
that this gets here
is by things like confirm
looks for certain kinds of things and it
probably doesn't look for timed out
dollar timed out is that a true
statement can somebody
confirm or deny that
i don't believe it looks for dollar time
doubt but i oh there we go it looks for
these things
right and certainly a failure to get a
lock is is a kind of failure even if
it's a time out right so
well the question is should confirm
trigger
on this failure
by default
because that's what this is if we say
it's a failure object then one of the
consequences of that is the confirmal
trigger
right
i mean there there are two ways to two
good ways to signal this condition one
is to generate an exception
and then we could either throw an
exception or we could return a failure
object that could be
subjected to confirm or the other way is
to signal that with a special value just
like end of file with signal that you
have reached the end of a file or so so
in any case i mean this will only appear
in code
where there is stuff around it that
actually deals with that case that
detects the timeout and then maybe
decide to do something else or to
abandon the computation and so on well
so basically what you're arguing for is
there should be a third argument with
lock
that has the possibility of specifying
the timeout condition
well i mean it's an option right i mean
no it's not an option the time
construction yes
seems useful to me
i mean it's a little weird that the
third argument would only be used if
there's an option setting for time
constraint
but having the possibility which third
argument which third argument
a third argument for what to return if
the time constraint fails yes which
would default to let's say a dollar
timed out but could be something
different
oh but if time constraint is an option
then it's kind of weird to have a
certain argument i know that's what i
just said right
um
i mean do we generally for example file
operations they don't give you a choice
of whether to return an exception or
return end of file or return a failure
object
you kind of want to documentation do
they return if you try and open a file
that doesn't um
no you
i'm not talking about errors i'm talking
about opening a file reading one line
after another until the file is
exhausted and then at the last time
right but that that doesn't enter
but that's an end condition i mean
trying to
get a lock if it failed you know if it
can't get a lock it can't perform its
operation
so i think that's a failure condition i
don't think that's analogous to end of
file right because you expect right
people write loops while you know
that doesn't equal end of file do stuff
people don't write things while i can't
get a lock
do stuff they're like really
yeah really
no i i'm pretty sure people do
i'm pretty sure that um
yeah yes well well they do but i i don't
think they would use a with luck
construction to do that
right i mean
they would separately get a lock and
then go in and do stuff right width lock
has both the body and the attempt to get
the lock
which is why i think it's weird
right isn't that what what with like
it's good because it's now atomic
and and
yeah no i i mean i i haven't been
following
the
explicit objection to the symbol dollar
timed out
but um it's not obvious to me
that i'm not willing to wait long enough
is actually a failure
fair enough
that's a that's a reasonable point
i mean that argues that dollar time
doubt is okay the question that still
remains is with all these functions that
can fail with time constraints what
should be the return value when they
fail with the time constraint and should
we give any any
should we potentially have an option
for
what they return in the time constraint
case what what does what does the url
read return
when it turns out
right it returns a failure object right
that's what why we decided to
not right the dollar time that was only
used i think in one place which was
maybe pink time
and um
uh
you know and things like url read and
whatnot returned failure objects so
[Music]
right there are no examples because
basically nothing was using it which is
part of what was thinking okay we'll
just keep this around for users to use
but system functions should use
should use failure objects yeah and and
now that i'm thinking about it slightly
harder
in java for example
when the analogous construct times out
what happens is an interrupted exception
um which is you know a very specific
kind of
failure you know that's distinguished
from a oh no something went wrong during
the operation
you know it's it's not failed to get the
lock exception it's um
just wasn't willing to wait long enough
except
so
i mean we don't i don't think we have
cases where functions actually return
also our exceptions yeah yeah so so so
the the
analog right
so so just because java throws an
exception doesn't mean that we have to
no
still a failure it's not it's not a you
know
special sentinel
return object
i mean is it
feasible to have
a very specific failure object that is
easy to recognize because to me it seems
these failure objects are kind of
kind of
nebulous and and don't have
and and i i just need something that is
always same cue to whatever i need to
test and so
all the time doubt was kind of
the most obvious choice i think this is
okay i think i think this is okay i
think we should leave it i don't think
we should change it it's already in uh
i don't think we should change it
okay well i mean it's in there as an
experimental function so
i see
um sorry
look okay
christopher isn't here is he
no
why don't we ask him since he's worked a
bunch on this confirm stuff and has
thought about these different error
conditions
um
i can work on getting him
okay
well
uh okay
down on our livestream is commenting why
don't just use failures with standard
tags like timed out that's what that's
what we would do if we use the failure
object for this the question is whether
whether we want to start the cascade
of things like confirm
failing when with lock returns a timeout
by default
okay let's keep going here
check all
what is this
it well there's the usage message it's
not documented the
um and i think it's
a good thing that it's not documented
because it
i think
i don't think it's quite right yet um so
but roman isn't supposed to do
um
it's
well the usage message is right there it
evaluates an exception
an expression and
applies
and sort of and applies a function which
returns
uh the
um
[Music]
the the evaluated expression plus held
versions of any expressions generated
any exceptions
yeah
but
um
okay this is this is part of what
general problem
okay let me tell you why i use it and
why i thought it would be useful i use
it as a kind of recursive call to
devaluate so i want to evaluate some
expression but i have to guarantee that
i always
get back control after it evaluates and
at the moment we don't have anything
that doesn't let at least one of our
many exceptions and so on escape
and so
i use it for
sending expressions to subkernel for
parallel computing because i need to
make sure that they don't escape the the
wrapper and i get the result back so i
never look at this hold complete i just
always use checkout of x bar comma hash
ampersand just to get the stuff back and
i don't
and
when you do recursive evol
evaluation any
unhandled exception is an error just
like in our top level so i don't really
care about those
but of course if you documented it then
it should have it should do something
sensible with these
with these
arguments if we want to keep it that way
so okay hold on so what are you really
using it for
as a recursive evaluator that is
guaranteed to not
escape right well that's that's a
completely crazy name for that so
guaranteed to not escape as in
there is no whatever whatever is inside
whatever expert may do
with the possible exception of quit
i get back control
and it doesn't
uh i understand so even if there's a
throw for example yeah that you
propagate through that just like our top
level just like a top-level eval
yeah i understand i understand so you
know we have this concept of controlled
evaluate which is essentially a
sandboxed evaluator that's what you want
but you want a rather trivial version of
the sandboxed evaluator
i mean i can i can live with anything if
we have something better right but this
is a hack i mean using a check all which
is intended for something completely
different for that the problem you're
trying to solve which is to have a
sandboxed evaluator is a perfectly
sensible problem
and one that we should have a function
for
right that mimics the top level of the
main loop
right that's what you're talking about
yes yes
right so i mean
i think that should be controlled
evaluate
which we planned and i don't know what's
happened to control the value does
anybody know
anybody
i i don't think so i mean
other than other than the name i don't
know that we have any actual design of
what this thing should be but we have
things we have evaluation data
the the cloud uses evaluation data but
that
essentially tells you the time it took
to evaluate something it makes no effort
to actually contain
side effects but the cloud no it does it
tells you messages it tells you prints
yeah but it's not it's not fail-safe i
mean
oh sure
no okay let's just okay guys we don't
have the right people in this meeting
but the cloud has a mechanism for doing
controlled evaluate
that's how it works that's how
lots of things like apis in the cloud
work
okay and i think we should make that a
top level function with other things in
the control evaluate like can it access
the file system and so on and roman
doesn't care about those things he just
wants don't let it throw
out you know don't let it throw things
outside of itself
right yes well i mean
control the value i mean they they use
the sandbox and they use evaluation data
each of which control certain aspects
but right right and and they also and
they also use a couple of catch wrappers
right right and the sandbox is once you
activate the sandbox into kernel no
right no file operations can be
performed or you know only certain very
restrictive
right that that's sort of a kernel-wide
state that's not i understand so that's
why i'm saying
that the way it should work is roman
wants you know the default
controlled evaluate can just be
controlled evaluative expert which
simply evaluates expert not allowing any
throw like escapes
am i making sense
and then
control evaluate
where where it says um
you know
uh um
[Music]
you know i don't know prevent file
access or something i'm not sure what
the right like terms are but something
like this
should be right but but nothing like
that exists
well and the first thing exists the
second thing doesn't exist
right and
the first thing exists and it's
basically a version of this check all
function right
sure but i i'm saying that right the
second thing doesn't exist in any way
that can be reused right okay fine fine
well then the first one is already
useful
right and we build out into the second
one over time
because the second one is useful we're
just not ready for it yet so where would
i find that controlled evaluated
but there isn't it doesn't exist i mean
it would be written
using the same code you know code path
that check all uses
see what i'm saying
i'm saying yeah rename
that piece of functionality from a
sensible a sensibly designed
check caller
right that just does the thing you want
nothing more
right just does what you want
now you know what i think we should do
is we should have a controlled evaluate
that for example
has you know memory constrained you know
memory constraint arrow whatever things
like that should be possible
i don't know how they will work yet and
i don't know you know how the file
access thing will work but i think
having this
to do just
the recursive main loop basically makes
sense
and then we can look at what it would
take to build out prevent file access
does that make sense to people
yes
i mean
i mean we
have discussed these restriction
languages
multiple times i think it's probably a
major undertaking but
well
we have pieces of that already although
we are less interested as we get more
containerized we're less concerned about
it
um you know in the cloud and so on
but still
it you know it's something that we need
to
also be great for testing right
yes that's true i'm surprised qa doesn't
have something like this
i'll probably just fire up a kernel and
see what happens right
into a local local local submit right i
think this is a good thing and i think
we should build it but i think the first
thing is just this which is very
straightforward and it's just based on
check all
okay let's move on to the next item
unless anybody has further comments
about this but i i would like to get
this
as a project that presumably is an ece
like project
okay so if we can feed it to that group
that would be good
yep got it
all right next up
before we go on did christopher join us
or
we're still working on getting him not
yet then then drop that let's just move
on we'll we'll do another time
um
right so this was some idea that
you know
it was discussed about
temporary echo and progress indicators
and since none of the
you know was discussed in an ild meeting
and since you know none of the progress
indicator
people
are in ild then
you know this
wants to be discussed here
so right so the concept do you
understand the concept that i i'm not
sure that i do okay so the concept is
you have a thing that is spewing out
echoes
okay
but
really what you want
is
to just have those echoes
show up
in either
a
great big blob
in something that will be a temporary
print
or
as a kind of ticker tape that keeps on
refreshing
in a progress bar
you see what i'm saying
okay so this is
i i don't understand the connection to a
progress bar i mean
echo is something that you put in to see
i know
question is where is it displayed right
so a generic echo just says you know
it's just displayed as a print cell
basically okay
okay so now there's the possibility of
echo temporary
which we don't have right now an echo
temporary does a print temporary so that
it disappears when the you know when you
hit the main loop again
yep okay
okay so then the other idea would be so
that that means even if i've got a
thousand echoes they all go blah blah
they all you know scroll up my own
notebook and then they all disappear
when the next input line comes in right
right
okay so an alternative to that is like a
progress monitor the echoes come in and
you know you could have an echo that
says doing this doing that doing the
other thing and they show up like things
in the progress bar show up as you know
things that are replaced when the next
when the next item comes in
that make sense
okay and so this is not
something that is
so so this is not connected to any
actual
progress indicator of that's correct
it's not a not about any it is a user
supplied
indication of progress
okay
okay
yeah i don't know what that means until
i mean i would assume that means it's a
separate bar that would come up that
would be somehow
a you know like you have a rapper
that says capture all the echoes from
inside this wrapper and put them into
this um
sort of ticker tape like thing that is
showing up
as
like a progress monitor
okay and this would affect all echoes
inside so echo would magically
change its behavior
or you need to use it you'd need to use
the temporary echo no no this is what we
the problem is we don't want to have
a
okay here is the problem
we've got i think it is a much better
design
instead of going we've got many echoes
you know uh echo evaluation echo label
echo timing all these kinds of things
there's many echoes
okay so rather than
turning each echo into an echo temporary
the idea was to have a wrapper around
the whole expression that says every
echo that would have been echoed to the
you know this is a modern functional
version of what in version one
was
change
uh whatever it was called dollar
what is it called i forget what it's
called dollar
dollar
dollar urgent or dollar dollar
there's dollar echo there is a dollar
echo right in dollar urgent which i
forget the exact difference between them
but
dollar echo is the thing that was
intended for terminals that echoes the
input line i believe
oh yes that yes that's right and dollar
urgent is the sort of right that's like
the steadier version but you right you
can redirect steadier to what you know
yeah right you can redirect it wherever
and then you can
right and so what i'm saying is this is
a version this is a functional version
of that
that says
redirect
everything in this block
okay so it would say um
i don't know what the right name for
this is but it's a wrapper that says
you know it basically says redirect
all
i mean let's say
uh
i mean i'm this is a very bad name but
let's say it's redirect expo redirect
echo rather of expo
that means during the evaluation of
expert
you know redirect this to
do you get what i'm saying
echo control
sounds like it sounds like some kind of
air traffic control concept right
yes i i would i would think like
redirected echo would probably be but
remember we've got several different
cases we've got case one
is
uh
make it make everything temporary but
have it but have it be there you see
what i'm saying
make the things temporary but have them
scroll off the page
and then the other cases make the kind
of ticker tape thing and i think there's
even another case as well which we don't
have yet which is like do something like
put it in the footer here
you know there are other kinds of
echoing that i can imagine other kinds
of places to put the echo
right so like an attached cell at the
bottom you mean for example yeah
yeah or or i suppose at the top right i
mean that that seems like a perfectly
natural
right let's start right if those are not
evaluation
those are not orthogonal though yeah you
could help them if you put them in a
cell you have the same issue do you
replace or you keep adding them
or well that's that's what this function
has to control i mean is it a
replacement or an addition type thing
is it a continuous replacement and one
could even imagine a case where you want
two of them kept and it keeps cycling
through
right the main point is to have a
wrapper that controls where the echoes
go
that's good just for all the echo
something functions there's nothing else
that you should copy
that's correct
right so i guess so so let me ask julia
this question i mean
do you
let's focus just on the case of the
ticker tape
is this something
that could be built using evaluate with
progress or using pieces of evaluate
with progress or is this really
its own thing that
uh
that
would need to work
with with you know possibly with
suggestions from you
i
don't see the connection i mean the the
the connection is a wrapper around the
envelope but
that's like uh
like any other uh
right
unless we want to to have some styling
to put them in a in a similar panel but
this would be weird because it can be
any expression it can be a long list or
or a word
and i think this is also
sort of echo styling right right that
little orangey thing or with an hour i
think it should be something that has a
style reminiscent of the progress
monitor bar style but perhaps slightly
different
but the main issue look the main thing
is and one question is should this be
generalized also to print
why would it be useful what's that
what why not
well
i
i mean print is very much in the in the
file operations world i i
i i'm not sure that's really something
we want to go to well and then there's
cell print which get gets even more
complicated
i mean i think echo echo is the modern
print in many ways
except it has this very nice feature
that you know you can just wrap it and
you know the return value is what it
printed whereas print
has
the you know feature that it can print
multiple things but the return value is
null
and
honestly if we thought about that more
carefully
back in 1987 or something we probably
would have made the return value the
expression itself as echo has
probably maybe not actually well no
because then you couldn't have
had the secret the the sequence form
and you and the sequence form is used a
lot in print i mean i i guess you could
have made everybody use uh
what was it uh sequence form i guess was
the pre
row row
but yeah it would have been a mess right
so not obviously a design mistake but
but um
you know
okay let's let's concentrate this on
echo then
and there's nothing else
right okay my only concern with this is
that the the size of the expression will
vary widely like an equal evaluation can
be very big
what
equal evaluation
it it can be big you get some arguments
in it can be a long list
i don't know what people typically uh
use echo for but
so what i mean okay so listen you're
making an argument that this echo
control or whatever it's called
should also have something that says
auto shorten
not really more than that we should have
to to think the design carefully because
this uh
like for example adding that to a cell
how big we want that cell to be
so it's a question of what the user
wants if the user says i want to see
everything that echo produces
right they're not going to want it
shortened but there's no reason we can't
have something in echo control or
whatever it's called
that
you know that specifies make no echo
longer than 100 characters
and then it will shorten it
which also may be just fine depending on
the use case
then we need probably to fix short
before
well that's something that should happen
anyway but but but okay so so the things
we're doing here okay so let's just
understand for echo control or whatever
it's called do we have a better name
than echo control
well i like redirected echo
at least i like it better i wouldn't go
so far as saying it
that i like it but i like that better or
maybe directed echo
there was an echo monitor
it's another suggestion we have echo
monitor what no what no
no the problem with that is that that
suggests that we are monitoring the
echoes and
what we're really doing is redirecting
the echoes
right
the thing that okay wait a minute
we also have quiet echo right
do we yes we do
okay
so quiet echo is is a version of
something like this
um
right and all the echoes inside of it
disappear right so if you do echo at x
if you put echo in front of that xxx
then we should see nothing
if
right
if i remember i remember this thing
being proposed i didn't remember it but
implemented wait a minute oh that
returned xxx that's correct yes but it
didn't echo xxx
correct
yeah that's right okay so so this is so
redirect echo makes sense along with
quiet echo
yep
that's a pretty sensible name then
because it really does say what you know
if you see
if you so you'd say redirect echo
okay the only thing which bothers me
about redirect echo is there's no
redirection if you're just making it
temporary it's in the same place
right and and well i guess the other
question is are all the redirections
temporary redirect you know no i i think
you should be able to redirect to a
random other notebook if you want to
and have your echoes you know like have
your much like we have the the console
yep
right so we don't want a name with
temporary in it and and redirect is
we don't we neither want redirect nor
temporary really because both of those
unless those uh
um
maybe target echo
well echo target but but then
well
no no
you're targeting the echo
yeah but i guess that's very easy to
catch the possibility of
um yeah it's not even tough
that
we're trying to control both where
the echoes go and
how
new echoes are added like what the
actual echo behavior and whether it's
temporary whether it's i mean we're
controlling
okay is it is it location and then we
manage echo okay
yeah with something like that except we
know i don't have anything called manage
um
right
uh
okay so so the things we're trying to
control are
um
i mean in a sense okay we're trying to
control
uh
where does it go
where does it where does it get printed
or possibly not even printed or possibly
accumulated
we're trying to control
uh is it temporary
is it temporary
um
and you know
in the evaluation in the main
loop and we're also trying to control
how do actually how do multiple echoes
you know multiple echoes work
is it you know replace
add
etc and we're also trying to control
um
constraints on the echo itself eg short
yeah that's that's a lot of things to
pack into to one word
well
yeah i'm i'm i'm just commenting on on
why we're not why we're not instantly
coming up with the name
i'm not saying that this i'm not saying
it's a bad function i'm just saying that
that makes it hard to come up with a
good name
um
where should i store this
this is something new so um
i've been functional programming yeah
this is horrible i mean i'll i'll store
it here but it's horrible
um
all right what are some other words like
manage target
control
what else do we do where it's a wrapper
like this
that
controlled echo
that controls the problem is that it's a
it is
that suggests that it's not i mean like
quiet echo well i mean quiet could be an
adjective but i'm imagining that quiet
there is more of a verb
um
where does it get printed let's see
multiple
um
well the thesaurus suggests dominate
dominate echo
no
um
is that the synonym for manage that's
terrible yeah well well that was for
control
oh there's supervised which is maybe a
little bit closer
yeah but that's that's a crazy word i
mean
that's that's a harness the echo harness
so to speak
right it says uh
yeah
um
this really is it's it's a wrapper of
some kind it's it's a it is like a
harness it's it controls
um
i'm not sure i actually like this but
the thesaurus for manage also suggests
organize
which is in some sense what we're trying
to do here we're trying to organize the
echoes but
i don't know that that
um
guided echo
i'll write it down dad is suggesting
echo regulate
regulate
yeah
peter there on our live stream like a
regular
the problem is okay so we've got
quiet echo the problem is okay we've got
echo timing echo evaluation etc those
are all
the
echoes that do things
this really i think should be verb echo
it's its form should be something like
that
what about something like transform echo
that sounds very mathematical
but i understand the concept
um
translate echo but it isn't translated
something like that
uh
place echo
filter echo filter echo
you're not really filtering them echo
placement is not absolutely terrible
perhaps
um
it isn't just the placement though it's
also whether it's temporary or not
by the way let's let's ask that question
i assume we want one function so the way
it's going to look
this this function is you know because
what we ended up with with the echoes is
we said well you could have echo
function with all kinds of arguments but
it's really convenient and i use it all
the time to just be able to say echo
timing or echo evaluation whatever and
see and just have that one thing that
you could you could um
you could put in
there um
so perhaps we want more than one
function here i mean
you know
um
you know maybe we want
uh
you know this is a very bad name but you
know one of them is temporary eyes the
echoes
and then there can be
see see what we're going to want here
okay so except yeah i mean i i think the
problem with the direction you're headed
in right now is that they're not
necessarily
right these are not necessarily
orthogonal axes like i know i know i
know that's what that's what we had in
the echo functions themselves and what
we did there was we have like echo label
you can both echo function and let go
label you can get the same functionality
they're both three argument functions
but they curry differently
no
right
they're they're only operator forms
echo well i only use it okay wait a
minute echo function is an operator form
but what about an echo label the label
is also an operator form
[Music]
okay okay it's the missing operator form
for echo
i see so echo itself
is just an operator has only one
operator form
that is effectively the the one argument
form because it can't do anything else
as an operator yeah so it's equivalent
really an operator operator our echo
function and echo label those two
functions give you the different i see
are the operator forms of the different
arguments of echo
correct
right but but yes and i may but i'm
making a slightly different point which
is right if you are going to place the
echoes in a file or in the messages
window you can't make those temporary
right you can understand
but i'm just saying
okay so look
here's a possibility
let's imagine
i mean this may be wrong but let's just
try
uh
no
okay what i'm looking for here is
the thing that temporarizes things
they're really two cases here that are
that are going to be common
one is you just want all the echoes to
clean themselves up after the evaluation
is finished
right that's case one and case two as
you want them to be
sort of all on all on one line replacing
each other
okay so let's imagine that we wanted
functions different functions for both
of those two things because both of
those things are things you want to slap
on an expression or slap off an
expression and the last thing you want
to have to do
if you have a temporary eyes echo no you
see that's not going to work because you
want an operator form where you can just
stick it at the beginning of the
expression with an at sign and
definitely not have to go chasing to the
end of the expression to add some weird
option to it
but we could just
use a different destination for the
tempo from if we had a destination
so you could say destination is a cell
or it's a temporary cell or it's a
notebook or a file or i know but you
don't want to do that because you just
want one word that you're going to slap
around you know the use case is like
quiet like quiet echo is you've got this
big thing you put a bunch of echoes into
it and it's like oh i just don't want to
see those echoes that's just not you
know put one thing at the front
not let me go and write code where
there's a thing at the beginning of the
thing at the end
of programming
yeah i i well right but this thing is
right right this thing isn't going to
need to be hold hold all
and so it can't be
it can't have an operator form
right hold on hold on hold on there's a
there's a question
look
okay so what arguments does it have to
have temporary eyes echo
it's whole okay that's its generic form
right
much like echo function and echo label
we are probably going to want
something that might be called echo
control okay so here's a possible idea
here's a possible idea
okay echo control
has a whole complicated set of
specifications here and it is a pure
operative form that takes expert here
you see what i'm saying but but right
these are not going to work right you
can you can't have an operator form at
least not if you want to catch all
echoes right because
the the it'll
control return to function
oh i suppose if echo control returned to
pure function with hold attributes then
i suppose that might work but then it's
not just a rapper but it doesn't need to
be just a rapper i never claimed it was
just a wrapper i claimed it just did
what it should do
yeah this is super ugly we never did
that i think the only place where we do
it is in the resource
sorry the functional repository there's
some
hack with the stock to be able to make
them holding
i don't know if it's a
thing we should propagate in the system
but that's the other possibility i am
aware of
um but but conceptually
would we like this i think we would i
think this would be pretty nice that you
would give what you would be able to do
is you would be able to say i've got
this whole echo control thing i set
um
i mean the alternative of saying echo
control
of exper comma
arguments here
is going to get pretty ugly pretty
quickly
i agree with you completely it's it's
the operative form is a perfect form for
this kind of the stuff that you want to
plug
at some point in the code is it's just
that our evaluation mechanism doesn't
play well with this
well we should probably figure that out
but let's talk about okay so this would
be the the do everything version okay
then what are the simple names
this is kind of the the do everything
then what are the simple names for the
common cases okay so what we want is the
common cases are
uh
you know output in an output in in a
scroll so to speak
but temporary
and
output with replacement
output in a progress bar
i think those are the two common cases
do you agree
i mean these cases where you're
redirecting the echoes to you know
someplace else those are more exotic
markown livestream is commenting why is
temporary echo temporary
what kind of cell does echo temporary
no i'm sorry just echo echo outputs to
what kind of cell
an echo cell
okay fine
yeah okay
um one day by the way we should replace
those
change times with date objects of some
kind
uh
personally i think we should just
eliminate those change times because
they needlessly contribute to diff
for no particularly good reason
i find them very useful
maybe there's a different way to handle
them
i understand your objection as well
let's that issue let's let's put that
issue on the docket for another time
okay okay
i i understand your point also
um
okay output on a scroll but temporarily
what would we call that
um
okay the the suggestion here from um dan
echo configuration
that's another possible name
um
marco is commenting about channels we
actually have channels
rather um they're not particularly
widely used although we use them for
some purposes we have a pretty good
channels mechanism
um
although that's an interesting
possibility i mean in other words could
we output
um
you know
is this even is that a crazy thing to do
it's not a crazy thing to do you could
output for example to a logging server
through a channel
i i've never seen anybody do that i'm
sure we do that
for some internal purposes but i've i've
not seen that in user code
not that i see that much user code
except my own
um
right i mean this is
uh
that's an interesting idea that that
might be a relevant place to send
messages
anybody great although i think
i i think that just means we need uh
right there needs to be some way of
specifying a pure function
in addition to sort of name strings of
yes and operations i don't think you
know we're not going to do anything
specifically for that i mean this will
be basically a
um make sure
there's a function
to say what to do with the message with
the echo payload
okay
so
again
what would we call this
it's a wrapper
that makes what's inside it
um
ephemeralize echo
i don't think that's a word but what um
what do you do to make something
temporary
and then what do you do to make i mean
this would be again i think it's two
um
it's too whimsical
is the first one like
temporary echo batch
like all of the echoes in there are
temporary together
well
we could also because we're not using
echo temporary we could imagine
well okay that's a question do we also
want echo temporary
which is the local echo being made
temporary
if you're putting just one echo into
your code you might want echo temporary
just as a single you know a point
temporary echo
the problem with echo temporary is we're
not supporting echo function temporary
blah blah blah blah blah
which is the same problem we have with
echo timing and echo evaluation
that what that we're not supporting they
don't have operator forms
so this thing where you have to like
wrap your code
in brackets and supply additional
arguments is right okay sometimes
unavoidable with echo timing and echo
evaluation
and i think
i think it's more or less
right with temporary two right because
you need to still be there at the end to
to uh
you know clean up after the evaluation
has happened okay so let me suggest this
weird possibility
um
that this is not a serious word okay
but would something like this work
that doesn't really have a lot of
advantage
oh yes it does because it has different
that's a point temporarization
as opposed to
in other words when does the block clear
right so this one
you know clears only at the end of the
only at the main loop
right as opposed to
uh
this
kind of temporary
echo
of exper
which clears presumably this clears
clear on exit from the temporary clear
on exit from this function
well i mean i don't see how those can be
different well so you could have one
cell with multiple different
temporary echoes
and when all of the echoes disappear
would depend on which temporary echo
they were wrapped in
yeah exactly so i'm sure but i don't see
the the difference between those two
inputs right at the end of the day you
have
a thing that's wrapping a single i mean
even if we made the first one work by
evaluating to
pure function withholding attributes
right i mean you base it right the the
the temporary echo lives
with uh
you know with the same scope relative to
expert so it would have to clean up when
expert was done evaluated but it can
have a its own scope within like
you could have
you
each temporary echo would give a
a sub scope within the main loop
where you clear echoes
i see right
but right but i thought the point yeah i
suppose right but you you could do that
just as easily by having you know
multiple
temporizes right
wait a second look it seems to me there
are two cases if you are point
temporizing an echo the only possible
scope for that is the main loop
but you mean
the main loop it's when you exit when
you you exit the function
no no when you exit when you reach okay
what causes
print temporary to clear answer when you
hit the main loop
right temporary on input line 17
clears
when output line 17 has been is
generated
and not before
right it's global to the main loop
[Music]
i
that that's the way it works oh i get i
guess yeah
okay so that that's the case and that's
a useful case
right i know what it does with dialogues
and things like that it's more
complicated but i don't think it's that
important that's a useful case the
second useful case is it is a rapid
temporarization where you've got a big
function that is going to be you know
your time-consuming function
uh
you know for example i can imagine
mapping across 10 things
and saying temporary echo by the way i
would like to just make a pin a
particular issue which is what to do
with echoes from parallel processors and
particularly what to do with this
temporary echoing from parallel
processors and how those get cleaned up
how does that work with a progress
monitor when i have a parallel evaluate
uh poorly
um
giulio and
if roman is still here i mean we have
some support but there are some issues
at least and there's at least one pr to
fix one of those issues that what was
the question sorry
if you focus monitor and work with
parallel processes
it i guess it depends us on
how the the question is framed like uh
are you paralyzing a function that
supports
uh
and has the uh
of like video frame extra video
structure right so you say parallel
table
of 25 videos okay you've got them
running on diff 25 different cores
and
they each have a progress monitor that
they'd like to stick their hand up and
wave their hand and say i've got this
far in my in my evaluation
can they do it do you see 25
well
with the new changes to the targeting
the
the proper cell if they can reach the
actually i haven't tried that but i can
uh the in principle they could print 25
progress bars
if each one of them
but it really depends on how the the
function is parallelized
like
if it is just calling the same function
20 times then it
will probably spin 20 progress bars
there are functions that do have native
support for parallelization
and
and the function called by the parallel
table generates a progress monitor
that's okay
what's that so i need to look at this
with julio because i mean
i must admit that i've never tried this
okay so i also never tried but in my
case i think i have 157 cores hooked up
right now so that's going to as soon as
i get progress monitors from 157 cores
it's going to cover my screen
possibly i mean right now the progress
monitoring utility is not aware of being
called inside
a power evaluation
um
so
it's not doing anything different let's
not get let's not get dragged into that
issue by the way it's a suggestion from
ethan on our live stream which i think
is a very interesting suggestion which
i'm surprised we haven't thought of
before which is why not have a right
click menu that adds echo
just like we have one here
for
i mean i use this i can eyes one all the
time
in fact i use it right click menu for a
while everything else in this
right-click menu put together
have a right-click menu for what echo
wrap echo around this thing
um
you know you select a piece of code here
you right-click you press add echo
i know that seems pretty darn
specialized to me
you can just do echo function at
um
i think it's an interesting suggestion
which we should at least think about
there are explorations around that sort
of thing happening in the toolbar design
oh that's a good place for it that's a
very good place for it yeah along with i
can eyes yeah that's a good place
actually now that you mentioned i
remember this
okay so so let's come back here
um we had some other suggestions and i
need to
go on a minute here um transient echo
now the problem is we're using the word
temporary
for print temporary so we're kind of a
little bit cooked in on on
on the temporary word rather than
transient
echo shell
interesting
trace
ethan is asking why does the monitor
work automatically with table and do
automatically in other words for
parallel table we've added
uh the progress monitor why don't we do
that for table
interesting question
i mean i think if we get these progress
monitors shaken down enough i don't see
why we shouldn't add it
well i'm sorry what's the question
okay parallel table in this version
has an automatic progress monitor
okay
i don't know what the timeout is before
you know this probably doesn't come up
if it only takes two seconds or
something
rowan probably knows what that yeah it's
one second
okay fine
um
okay the question is what about
automatic progress monitoring for table
right uh well i mean
that
i mean i suppose in principle that could
be done right that's going to be much
more
much more risky right because the
parallel code is already in top level so
it can run
other top level stuff i mean
if if we're going to make every single
table make extra loops through the
evaluator that's
that's not good so i mean
we've started thinking a little bit
about how to add progress indicators
that are deep in the c code but it's not
uh it's not by any means
something we're ready to show to the
world
okay oh so we we need to
progress sorry to go ahead with that
idea from john of uh
adding metadata about evaluation in the
on the on the link because right now we
the the the query for evaluation cell is
expensive and there's no way we are
adding that overhead to to any c
function
right
you understand what i mean yeah yeah
if every table requires an extra half
second because it needs to call out to
the front end that's nice
oh oh what ethan was suggesting is
actually a better idea which was not
what i understood he said this is what i
get for not eating my lunch i don't
can't think properly
what he's suggesting is
why doesn't monitor if you just give a
one argument form of monitor why doesn't
it automatically monitor
the
i don't know whether it's the nearest
you know in other words that's a good
idea that's a good idea so a form where
if you've got a table in there just like
you can say
you know echo the table you could say
monitor the table that is a very good
idea yeah i think we we had this uh in
early meetings when when we we never
went uh uh
around documenting the public form or
the other progress wrapper but one idea
was support specific heads and
i mean if people like monitor we can use
monitor as a function allows one to do
with monitor what one does with echo
which is just inserted in code remove it
from code this is a very good idea
i don't know also make monitoring
functional operations possible right
so that again
well it would make
monitoring functional
programming possible yes it would
because you could just say monitor of
you know map
of whatever
i can have a not particularly efficient
prototype with this
ready pretty soon i think that would be
great this is a really good idea thank
you ethan
um
the uh it's a very good idea i really
like that idea
um okay but this comes as brings us back
to
what we need i think is we need the
general echo controller function
that allows one to do redirection and
all kinds of things then we need the two
uh
um
ah monitor progress in the function
repository being pointed to okay
um
uh okay the other the other suggestion
here from craig is
is save the output of an echo of echoes
to a data set
i mean that's that's something which in
the echo controller that's something we
should it's a possible destination i
agree it will be more naturally a list
but that's a possible
destination
um
okay so again we've got several names
here to work out
okay
in a scroll but temporary in a progress
bar
and the overall control
does that make sense
um
in a progress bar overall control and
i said look one of them is the big
scrolling collection just like print
temporary so that name has to be has to
resonate with print temporary because
it's going to basically do the same
thing
um
and i really need to get going here um
all right well we can
pick it up right i mean i i i still yeah
i mean i still think we need
their
details to be thought through but we can
pick this up another time
okay yes i mean there's several details
there but this has been useful i mean we
really want we want three names here
okay all right so
ticker tape
well i mean the obvious one for the
temporary one is echo temporary that
behaves just like print temporary only a
deck no it doesn't no that's wrong that
would be a fourth thing that is the
local echo temporary okay
that's a different thing this is a
rapper
oh so okay so so you're saying uh we
you're saying we want
everything right the big the big guy all
right the big rapper right as opposed to
the point echo that is supposed to be
temporary and i think maybe the right
thing to do i don't like this i don't
like this because echo function and echo
label are both very useful and we do not
want to have echo function temporary
echolabel temporary
so we need another way of doing that of
being able to take an echo
label or echo function and somehow do
something like this kind of wrapping
okay so we don't have to replicate
functions there something like echo
cancellation
[Music]
that's funny
i mean we should record that as a as a
i don't know what um
i don't even know how to spell how much
cancellation is an american is spelled
with two l's or one l
two
okay good it's not many of those words
don't double that the letters in
american english um
well there there's well it could be echo
clean up or clean up echo
well that could be this one here but
again
oh my gosh
okay requires more thought we don't know
right now okay
see you guys later thank you all thank
you folks on the live stream i think i
have another live stream coming up in a
few minutes
um okay see y'all soon